this episode is presented by supercards
it's not just any haircut it's super
cuts
[Music]
after avengers end game broke the
multiverse one division broke the
multiverse oh god you don't know what
you've done what if broke the multiverse
loki broke the multiverse spider-man
broke
you see where i'm going with this
dr strange will break the multiverse
again in doctor strange in the
multiverse of
madness get ready for a spooktacular
sequel
full of gore that would shock a 13 year
old raised without internet
scary monsters like uh bees
and the creeping feeling of dread that
marvel doesn't know what to do with the
x-men or fantastic four
should we be concerned i'm kind of
starting to get concerned boner
homeopathic iron man returns and no
matter what he says i'm happy he's sad
now i am happy you sleep next to an open
laptop you're not filling anybody catch
up with the sorcerer supremes regional
assistant manager who was once as strong
as thanos but lately is weaker than math
math and watch his streak of elves
continue
as he's outworked by his own cave
[Music]
tries to make ray chap in it was never
gonna work out between us it's not gonna
happen i love you in every universe
and dies for the infinitive time
[Music]
see this is why my top three doctor
strange movies are avengers 3 spider-man
3 and thor 3.
welcome back franchise favorites like
wong
and
okay basically just wong i apparent
who which is why marvel had to call
their mommy i'm a mother when you last
saw her wanda maximov was trapped in
classic sitcoms working her way through
complex emotions like grief and
acceptance
now her character is trapped in a
hallmark movie working her way through
questions like women do be acting crazy
though sometimes right fellas
[Music]
watch the scarlet witch turn full wicked
off camera and try to burn down the
multiverse in a single-minded search for
her made-up children that she won't shut
up about my children my children i dream
of them my boy for billy and tommy i
just want my boys really copy i could
just be a normal white lady and get a
rescue dog or save your dead husband you
remember him i blew a hole through the
head of the man i left
one of the all-time great comic book
legends has returned
sam raimi
watch a director with his own unique
spin on zombie and superhero movies get
asked to you know do that again
but don't worry foggy's still serving up
that sameness you crave full of mcu
comfort slop like commercials for the
next movie you caused an incursion then
we're gonna fix it oh that's
clear from the comic books
i knew that
action sequences that look worse than
marvel vs capcom
centrist politics that pair subtle nods
to gay rights with subtle nods to
burning books with naughty words in them
and the latest variant of this
universally hilarious joke there was an
incident with spider-man what man black
bolt again hit a guy there the illumi
star-lord who i need you to be the
ant-man as a tool to change the name a
unimined
[Music]
was that a new thing bad guys give
themselves bad names your name is
taserface dr otto octavius
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
gets funnier the more times you hear it
right
witness a film that explores the
limitless possibilities of the
multiverse for one whole
scene
really can we go back to paint world for
a sec no okay no i don't know how okay
settle for the mcu's bogus journey
across the multiverse where the
differences are all cosmetic we're going
red the characters barely change you
know you hated me where i came from and
i bet secretly my brother you hated me
here and the plot devices are either
literal convenience stores replay your
significant memories
or even main characters like america who
just like her namesake means well
believes a trail of destruction and fast
food wherever she goes preferably pizza
pizza balls so if you only watch one
film this year about a young woman
traveling the multiverse to find their
mother where people learn to project
themselves into their alternate timeline
cells and the poster looks like this
please see everything everywhere all at
once instead i know a lot of you been
asking for an honest trailer for that
one so here it is it's way better than
doctor strange there you go
starring
a quirked up goateed white boy with a
sauce
i think you need snickers you're kind of
a witch when you're hungry
citizen starlight
it's more than time supreme
disappointment on the spot wonderful
the taco water coffee the time
traveler's ex-girlfriend
the olson's twins
fox and friends
mom spaghetti
i can do this all day governor
campbell's lube
a bull as a china cop and eyeball stuff
[Music]
so
[Music]
doctor strange in one alternate universe
that's basically just the near future
dreams of windows into the lives of our
multiversal selves so it's nellie mcu
cannon that the dream you had without
seeing your dad naked in the bathtub
really happened sorry
this episode was presented by supercards
the smarter easier way to get a haircut
it's not just any haircut it's super
cuts check in today on our mobile app or
supercuts.com
you